president Trump has lit the bureaucratic
fuse for his new Space Command but the
idea comes with a hefty price tag and
plenty of critics national security
correspondent Jennifer Griffin looks at
both sides tonight from the Pentagon
this space command will be the 11th
combatant command in the US military the
announcement was timed to coincide with
the launch of the spacex falcon 9 a
long-delayed 500 million-dollar gps
satellite for the US military but the
mission was aborted until Wednesday I
can assure you that space was a priority
of this president and of his vice
president the president's memo
establishing the command is an effort to
consolidate the military space
operations and defend US assets in space
satellites the u.s. relies on for
navigation communication and
surveillance the new command is expected
to cost about 800 million dollars over
the next five years as the president
said and as you all well know space is
in his words a war fighting domain China
has tested missiles designed to destroy
satellites China and Russia are working
to station new weapons directly in space
the Space Command is the first step
toward president Trump's space force
which at first the Pentagon resisted
that my direction the Pentagon is now
working to create the sixth branch of
the American armed forces called the
space force woods dog the Air Force
which oversees space for the military
initially opposed the president's idea
I'm absolutely in favor of a separate
space command to provide that war
fighting focus but I am not in favor of
a separate space force a separate
military service it's bureaucratically
complicated it will be expensive it's
not necessary the US military had a
Space Command from 1985 to 2002 but it
was disbanded after 9/11 so that
northern command could be set up to
defend the homeland breath Jennifer
Griffin at the Pentagon Jennifer thank
you